I gave birth to my first baby at 19,
and now I'm pregnant,
about to give birth to my third baby.
So let's talk about birth.
I'm still very pregnant,
but we're getting closer to giving birth,
and this time around,
I'm doing another home birth.
I just wanna start out by saying that this is not for everyone,
and everyone should decide what they wanna do,
since it's their individual experience.
This is just what I prefer.
With my first,
I obviously didn't know a lot about birth and doctors and all of that,
so I just went to a normal doctor, um,
for all of my pregnancy checkups until I was at week 36.
And then
I just realized that I was not getting treated like a person would,
more like a number.
And I didn't like that,
so I switched over to a midwife,
and it was the best thing I could have done.
So I knew for my second baby,
I wanted to do a home birth
and just go with a midwife from the beginning.
And I had the sweetest midwife
that made me feel so heard and understood
and supported in whatever I wanted to do.
All of our appointments were an hour long,
and she listened to my concerns,
how I was feeling,
what I wanted to do.
And ultimately,
at 36 weeks, we came up with a good birth plan.
On the day I went into labor,
we had my husband,
sister Piper, her husband at the time,
me, him,
and then the midwives. Over.
It all started after I put rumble to sleep,
and as soon as she was asleep,
I induced labor myself by dry pumping and drinking this
insanely gross cocktail of things.
I sent lucky to get me a frosty from Wendy's.
I was craving it so bad.
And while he was gone,
my water broke and I started contracting.
So I called him to come home immediately.
He rushed home,
and at this point,
my contractions were so strong and really close together
that we decided to call our midwife.
I think she was about 30 minutes away,
and she barely made it in time.
Soon as she arrived,
I told her that I felt the urge to push,
so I started pushing,
and he was born.
Whole experience was pretty hands on for lucky and I,
because lucky was the one catching the baby,
supporting me through labor,
and the midwives were there to make sure that everything was okay.
Not even two or three hours later,
we were just in bed, snuggling our baby like nothing happened.
So for this baby,
we're planning the exact same thing.
Having a home birth,
probably laboring in my bedroom.
Hopefully my kids will be in bed by the time I go labor.
We ordered a homebreathing kit,
which basically is just a bunch of essentials you'll need,
like a mattress cover and other things,
and I can't wait.